welcome to this second panel of
Hillsdale college's Constitution Day
celebrations we're very happy to have
you here my name is Brad Watson I am a
professor of politics and I hold the
Philip M McKenna chair in American and
Western political thought at st. Vincent
College in the virtuous Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania one thing you need to know
about st. Vincent is it is the summer
training camp of the Pittsburgh Steelers
the only team in professional sports
that counts for anything aside from the
Pittsburgh Penguins I'm also a visiting
fellow at the Kirby Center here in
Washington this academic year where I'm
teaching a course on US constitutional
history in the current semester u.s.
constitutional history to 1865 and then
in the spring semester I will teach us
constitutional history from 1865 to the
end of times it's perhaps a sad sign of
the times that we convene a panel on
whether or not the Constitution should
be revised replaced or restored the
Constitution of course is now routinely
revised to suit the moment by
politicians who simply ignore it or
twist its meaning to suit their
ambitions or by members of that council
of revision we know as the Supreme Court
who routinely vote to amend the
Constitution without the consent of the
people even as they shamelessly
dissemble by claiming they're merely
interpreting it but the provenance
really of this contemporary almost
casual revisionism lies in those
progressives who lived a century or more
ago and who more honestly than current
liberals in my estimation called for the
outright replacement of the Constitution
by an alternative more centralized less
Republican model that would allow for
stronger leadership than the founders
would have countenanced in order to move
the country in political and moral
directions the founders would not have
recognized those progressives appeared
on the scene hard on the heels of the
American statesmen Abraham Lincoln who
most comprehensively sought to restore
the Constitution to the dignity and
glory
he thought it deserves because of its
conformity with natural rights rights
that do not change with time or the
dictates of convenience or ambition
Lincoln's call for restoration has been
echoed if only occasionally since his
time by men like Calvin Coolidge and
Ronald Reagan amongst others on the
other hand on the other hand one of the
facts that thoughtful people must
confront is that there are other
examples of limited constitutionalism in
the world today these other forms of
limited and limiting constitutionalism
structure the governments and societies
of countries that now rank higher on
various indices of economic freedom for
example then does the United States so
perhaps this question isn't quite as
settled as partisans of the American
Constitution as Hillsdale
constitutionalists might like we've
assembled a very fine panel to consider
just this and more to my far right
RJ post rito is graduate deamon
professor of politics at Hillsdale where
he teaches political philosophy American
political thought and American politics
he holds the Charles and Lucia Shipley
chair in the American Constitution he's
also a senior fellow of the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
and political philosophy and has
published several books including
Woodrow Wilson and the roots of modern
liberalism and has written widely on
progressivism in the administrative
state he earned his PhD from the
Claremont Graduate University in 1996
the most important thing you need to
know about RJ is that I've known him a
long time since we were students
together graduate students together I
could tell you stories they're stories
that shall we say might enhance the
reputation of Hillsdale College in some
ways at least and if you buy me drinks
after lunch I will happily tell you
those stories to my immediate right
Terry Moe is the William Bennett Monroe
professor of political science at
Stanford University and a senior fellow
of the Hoover Institution that blessed
place under the palms with the best
climate in the world demonstrated by
government tests or so they will tell
you yet he still manages to get work
done
he has written extensively on public
bureaucracy and the presidency
as well as the theory of political
institutions more generally his most
recent book is relic how our
Constitution undermines effective
government and why we need a more
powerful presidency he's also written
extensively on the politics of American
higher education including recently the
comparative politics of education
teachers unions and education systems
around the world to my left Frank
Buckley is a foundation professor at the
Antonin Scalia Law School at George
Mason University where he has taught
since 1989 previously he was visiting
old and fellow at the University of
Chicago Law School and he's taught at
McGill law school in Montreal and the
Sorbonne in Paris he received his BA
from McGill he did graduate work in law
at Harvard but we won't hold that
against him he's a senior editor at the
American Spectator and the author of
several books including the once and
future king the rise of Crown government
in America and the way back restoring
the promise of America like me Frank
hails from Canada I like to tell people
I'm a reformed Canadian and a reformed
lawyer now fully Republican in my
sensibilities and happily teaching not
law but political philosophy and in
particular the political philosophy of
the American Founding Frank is perhaps
an unreformed Canadian and an unreformed
lawyer but we shall see RJ
Thank You Brad it's true Brad Brad can
tell stories one thing he's serious
about he actually would like someone to
start buying him drinks right after
lunch thanks to Doug Jeffery Matt
Spaulding for asking me to speak on this
panel thanks for all of you for for
coming out I have to admit that when I
saw the topic and the the personnel
lineup for the first panel this morning
I had my doubts as to whether anyone
would be interested in this second panel
but here you are
so thank you and and of course the two
themes I think are very much connected
so so this is a first all to say
Hillsdale College event right so I'm
supposed to be I'm for the Constitution
that I get my I got that right I hope
and honestly I mean as Brad alluded to
in his opening remarks I think only in
the in the crazy kind of election season
that we've had does it make any sense
that we'd actually be having a Hillsdale
panel on this question on whether or not
we want to restore the Constitution and
I really do consider it a tragedy that
this is now a question among
conservatives and I say tragedy because
conservatives during the Obama years at
least until recently have been it seems
to me remarkably United on the response
to Obama's liberalism right if you think
about it the energy on the right since
2009 has been all about getting back to
the limited government constitutionalism
of our founders that that's where the
energy has been and for a movement that
has in the past been quite I would say
fractured on the question of the
American Founding the kind of
conservative coming together on this
question to my mind anyways since 2009
has been the great silver lining of the
Obama years
what an opportunity that has been for
those of us who hold those principles in
highest regard and likewise I would say
what a tragedy it is if today that
window of opportunity is closing so have
we missed the best opportunity we've
seen in generations to restore the
principles of the founding to their
rightful place and if we have by the way
I'm actually much less inclined than
some of my friends in the conservative
movement to blame mr. Trump for this
than I am the the arrogance of leaders
on our side who it seems to me I regret
to say have utterly squandered the
historic electoral victories with which
the Tea Party empowered them in 2010 and
in 2014 and who have utterly failed to
understand the nature of the energy that
fueled those victories and the
precariousness of the opportunity that
those victories presented so we've come
to this moment
where
we've come to this moment where
conservatives themselves question the
idea of restoring the Constitution now
this is a question that I do hear
sometimes from my students I should say
and I think from them it's quite it's
quite understandable especially few
understand the students at Hillsdale
College they they look at the state of
government they look at the state of
politics in our time and they wonder if
it isn't proved that the framers of the
Constitution did something wrong
couldn't they have foreseen the big
government liberalism of our time
couldn't they have therefore constructed
things more carefully they want to ask
haven't the anti-federalists warnings
about the power of the national
government proved true in our time now
part of my answer to students asking
such questions is to remind them that
even the most perfect Constitution on
its own is of course no guarantee of
success and this is something that was
well understood by our framers in which
we would do well to remind ourselves of
today I think before we talk too much
about revising or replacing the
Federalist Papers is a great source for
the explanation and defense of the
Constitution but for all of their
enthusiasm in defending the structure
and the mechanisms of the Constitution
Madison and Hamilton are very careful in
that book to emphasize that these things
are only what they call auxiliary
precautions their mayor mayor helps in
other words for the thing that is even
more important in defending the people's
Liberty and that is what they call the
vigilance of the people or the people's
quote vigilant and manly spirit so the
structure of the Constitution in other
words is there to help protect the
people from what are called temporary
errors and delusions right that's the
phrase that's used but no Constitution
can help a people whose vigilance in
spirit has become deeply and even
permanently corrupted so before when
asked if a constitution needs to be
revised or replaced one must first
determine it seems to me if the people
themselves are fit for constitutional
government and so have the people been
properly vigilant with respect to their
liberties if they haven't isn't the
first order of business to restore a
proper understanding of and an
attachment through the principles of
free government before we entertain
notions of revising or restoring a
constitution and so we might start with
an understanding of the principle
threats to our constitutional government
that have been tolerated in our time in
particular we seem to have tolerated
today the replacement of rule by consent
of the governed with rule by bureaucracy
and rule by courts regulatory agencies
are only in competition with our courts
on the question of who exercises the
most influence today on the great public
policy questions note the major thing
that agencies and courts have in common
neither are elected or accountable in
the ways that policymakers are supposed
to be in a Republican regime yet today
as elections come and go as new
legislators replace old ones these have
increasingly little actual effect on our
public policy instead if you think about
many of the major national policy issues
today you'll realize that the majority
of them are the result of regulatory
action by agencies not the direct result
of laws enacted by our national
legislature so as Congress debates and
votes one way for instance on
immigration policy or on internet policy
the real policies on these vital issues
and many others are actually being set
by administrative agencies it's the
Department of Justice for example that
is
made the most sweeping policy on
immigration recently doing so not by
implementing any change in law but by
changing its own regulations and it's
the FCC the Federal Communications
Commission that right now is setting
sweeping new policy on internet
regulation your elected representatives
in Congress have had nothing to do with
this nor have they had anything to do
with the federal government sweeping new
edict that every public school in the
country admit anyone to any bathroom
they choose male or female that's a
major policy obviously it directly
affects every public school child in the
country and it came not out of the
lawmaking process where voters have some
influence and where of course it never
could have been enacted but instead is
simply a decree of the Department of
Education you may recall going back a
little bit at the end of the Bush
presidency the recent Bush presidency
your elected representatives in Congress
debated and voted against the bailout of
automakers yet the Treasury Department
went right ahead and bailed out GM and
Chrysler quickly thereafter and at the
outside of the Obama administration the
Democratic Congress debated and voted
down cap-and-trade legislation and
following that the EPA has been
aggressively implementing greenhouse gas
regulations as if that vote never
happened the fact is that elections for
our political branches of government the
debates that take place there today
matter less and less now elections can
and do often change the makeup of
Congress and the presidency but as I
said elections have much less influence
over courts and agencies for example I'm
sure I don't have to revisit for this
audience that the very meaning of the
institution of marriage in this country
has been redefined by five unelected
liberals on the Supreme Court this is
exactly why one scratches one's head to
see but the favorite strategy of our
enlightened congressional leaders is to
run crying to the courts
of all places when faced with rule by
executive or bureaucratic decree and
they are shocked shocked when the courts
aren't terribly sympathetic and by the
way if you think they haven't been very
helpful lately just wait until the
president Hillary Clinton gets her
chance to appoint a generation of judges
to the Supreme Court into the circuit
courts around the country
so before we start thinking about
whether we need to revise the
Constitution in order to deal with our
sad state of affairs we should bear in
mind that our conservative leaders have
failed to remedy the situation not
because they have stuck with the
Constitution but because they have run
away from the Constitution and the clear
remedies that it already provides James
Madison of course and his explanation of
the Constitution's checks and balances
shows how the system is designed to give
each branch the best means of defending
itself from abuses of power by the other
branches and even worries that they have
over empowered Congress since it clearly
has the advantages in this system so
what has happened in Federalist 51
Madison says that each branch must
possess two things in order to maintain
a constitutional equilibrium that is not
only the tools necessary to defend
themselves but also the willingness to
use those tools when it is necessary
well Congress still possesses those
tools but it is not shown the
willingness to use them this has been
the case I think in two key areas first
Congress has refused to use its most
obvious power senator sessions referred
to this last night the control over the
purse to hold responsible the
bureaucratic agencies that can only be
funded by congressional appropriations
votes it is remarkable to me how much
Congress
I was itself to be pushed around by the
bureaucrats whose salaries it pays and
it wasn't too long ago when the
situation was much the opposite agency
administrators used to tremble in fear
at the prospect of being hauled before
an Appropriations Committee chaired by
the likes of John Dingell for example
because they understood that
congressional appropriators like Dingell
wouldn't hesitate to use the
appropriations process to make the
bureaucrats show them some respect today
by contrast consider the open and smug
contempt with which agency bureaucrats
treat the very members of Congress whose
votes are needed to fund their agencies
I'm sure many of you saw the arrogant
performance of IRS Commissioner Koskinen
as he was questioned before the House of
Representatives
about the targeting of conservative
organizations that is the prevailing
attitude now that Congress has made it
clear that it will not use the
appropriations process to hold
bureaucrats accountable consider that
when CFPB had Richard Cordray was asked
in a recent congressional hearing who
and his agency was responsible for a
spending decision in the hundreds of
millions of taxpayer dollars Cordray
smugly retorted why does that matter to
you and if you look that up on YouTube
and why not be smug when Congress will
not use the constitutional powers
provided to it to do something about it
yet even an elementary read of the
Federalist paper shows that the vesting
of the people's elected representatives
with the taxing and spending power was
among the most important guarantees of
popular Liberty okay so that's one way
that we could use the Constitution that
we already have to defend ourselves
another way is to stop acting as if the
Supreme Court gets a monopoly on
interpreting the Constitution this too
is utterly contrary to our
constitutional does
yet it is accepted as gospel by our
enlightened political leadership you
can't have a separation of power system
if only one branch gets to say
definitively what the Constitution means
and thus defines the powers of the other
branches Madison also addressed this
directly this time in the 49th
Federalist paper explaining as follows
quote that the several departments being
perfectly coordinate none of them it is
evident can pretend to an exclusive or
superior right of setting the boundaries
between their respective powers and
Madison knew that to hold otherwise
would mean that you'd have a situation
we see today where major policy
decisions are made by five unelected
lawyers and the other branches simply
throw up their hands as if that's how
it's supposed to be we let the supreme
court get away with this at least since
the Cooper V Aaron decision in the 1950s
partly because our elected
representatives find it safer for their
jobs to cede tough calls to the courts a
better way to do it however might be to
follow the example of Abraham Lincoln
thinking specifically of his response to
the Dred Scott decision the courts
conclusion in that case which partly was
that blacks could not be citizens of the
United States had to be obeyed Lincoln
said in that case with respect to the
parties in that case but that did not
mean he said that other branches of
government and the people themselves had
to accept as a general matter the courts
interpretation of the Constitution all
branches of course not just the judicial
branch swear to carry out their duties
in accord with the Constitution
Lincoln's Department of State for
example continued to issue passports to
blacks even though the court said in
Dred Scott that they couldn't be
citizens and this was entirely in
keeping with the Constitution's
separation of powers logic a logic which
we in our time
surely use a refresher on before we get
too excited about revising or replacing
that which we evidently no longer
understand and if it's the case that we
really have become as supine as these
examples that I've cited seem to
indicate that we're willing to suffer
abuse of our liberties from those whose
salaries and budgets we have the power
to control and that we're willing to
have our fundamental social institutions
upturned by five unelected progressive
lawyers then our Constitution is not the
problem we are the problem and a new or
revised Constitution no matter how
clever isn't going to help us so count
me in favor of restoring what Madison
calls the vigilant and manly spirit of
the people once we do that I think we
will find that the Constitution we
already have will be more than adequate
thank you
okay I'm Terry mo from Stanford I want
to start by thanking Hillsdale College
for inviting me to be here I suspect
that the basic argument that I have to
make is it going to sit well with the
people at Hillsdale and with most people
in the audience I know that you know I'm
the odd man out here that's why I'm here
but you know they invited me anyway and
I think it's more than just to like
throw tomatoes at me or whatever people
want to do well I I think it's because
they really value intellectual exchange
and debate and I really admire that and
I just want to say what an honor it is
to be here with you today so as you all
know we're up to our necks in the
presidential horse race that has
basically sucked up all the oxygen in
this country for the last year and a
half or more and this is really too bad
for many reasons but it's bad because
it's a distraction from what ought to be
the main event the point of the horse
race we forget and of all politics
really is to run a government
you know that's capable of dealing
effectively with the nation's problems
you know whether the government is a big
government or a smaller government and
whether it's run by liberal policies or
by very conservative policies whatever
the content or scope of those policies
government should be effective but
effective government is precisely what
we don't have America's greatest
challenge I think is that it is burdened
by a government that just doesn't work
very well and in many ways is totally
dysfunctional
so why is this so why are we burden by
ineffective government well that's the
question that William Howell and I
address in our book relic and what we
argue is that the fundamentals of an
answer can be traced back to the
Constitution which for all its admirable
qualities and we think they are indeed
very admirable imposes a structure of
government that is ill-suited to modern
times at least in certain key seer and a
certain key respects and that all
respects now Congress is right at the
center of that structure and right at
the center of the dysfunction as a
decision-maker
Congress is just inexcusably bad it's
utterly incapable of taking effective
action on behalf of the nation you know
most people point the finger at
polarization and they say that if we
could just like move toward a more
moderate brand of politics then Congress
could get back to the good old days when
it really did just a fine job of making
public policy for the country but the
problem with that is there never were
any good opal days the good old days
weren't good with some exceptions UN's
Voting Rights Act and some others
Congress has never been capable of
crafting effective policy responses to
the nation's problems for documentation
you might take a look at Peter Chuck's
new book why government so often fails
my government fails so often I believe
that's what it is
which provides an encyclopedic
compendium of historical evidence of
government failure over the last couple
hundred years it's really quite an
extraordinary book over 400 pages long
filled with information a failure
so polarization has made a bad situation
worse but it's not the underlying cause
of Congress's core inadequacies which
are baked into the institution's makeup
and not of recent vintage
Congress is an ineffective policy maker
because it is wired to be that way by
the Constitution whose design ensures
that legislators are electorally tied to
their districts into their states and
that they will be highly responsive to
the constituencies and special interest
groups that get them reelected so
Congress is just not wired to solve
national problems in the national
interest it's wired to allow hundreds of
parochial legislators to promote their
own political welfare through special
interest politics and that's exactly
what they do day in and day out year in
and year out right and if you wonder
about the bureaucracy you know
exercising discretion and how that seems
to depart from the Constitution why did
they have so much discretion they get it
from Congress
why is Congress building the bureaucracy
as it does giving the bureaucracy so
much discretion not overseeing them
effectively it all comes down on the
same thing members of Congress have very
distinctive incentives and those
incentives are rooted in their states
and their districts and what they need
to do to get reelected and the kinds of
things that you can think of that would
make government more effective or not
what's motivating them that's the
problem all right so with Congress's
pathologies rooted in the Constitution
the ultimate problem in this case is the
Constitution itself the founders crafted
to government 225 years ago for a simple
isolated agrarian society of less than 4
million people you know about the size
of Los Angeles today government was not
expected to do much and they designed a
government that couldn't do much you
know with Authority separated across the
branches and the government filled with
veto points to that made coherent policy
action exceedingly difficult still do
when government has been able to act
congressional law making his ticket
typically led to cobbled together
policy concoctions that are crafted as
they are on purely political grounds so
that disparate legislators with very
disparate interests can be attracted
into the necessary support coalition so
I get something you get something she
gets something they get something and
what we wind up with is some kind of
Christmas tree legislation that you know
makes us all happy because we get what
we want and all the groups get what they
want but does it actually solve any
problems no that's the problem because
the whole political logic of it is to do
what we need to do piece by piece
to cobble together a support coalition
it's not to do what we needed to do in
order to create an intellectually
justifiable coherent effective hole for
addressing the problems that are out
there that's not what Congress is about
that's not what it does and that's why
it's outputs are so weak and so
ineffective so look no further than US
tax policy which is not a policy at all
and it's a grotesque conglomeration of
thousands of special interest favors and
loopholes that's what it is or witness
the ways in which insurance companies
hospitals drug companies and other
vested interests profoundly shaped
Obamacare as it was being formulated
turning it into something that no one
would have designed that way if they
wanted a cost-efficient well working
system but Congress did that it wasn't
like the Democrats that did that this is
what Congress does to everything it
happened to be the Democrats this time
so this approach to governance may have
been fine for the late 1700s when there
wasn't much to do but that era is long
gone and it's not coming back within a
hundred years the nation grew to fifteen
times its original size and population
it spread all the way
to the Pacific Ocean and it was
developing explosively into a modern
industrial society generating countless
problems along the way from rapacious
monopolies the child labor to
unregulated drugs - filthy meat
processing you know to transportation
systems that needed to be built to great
need for sound money some way to achieve
it and on and on and on and on and on
all these problems well the founders had
never anticipated all this he didn't
know what modern government was gonna
look like they didn't know what
industrialized society was gonna look
like they didn't know about all these
problems that they would need a
government to solve those problems
because they lived a hundred years
earlier in a very very very different
society so by 1900 or so the government
that they had designed for their society
was already way out of sync with the
society it was now supposed to be
governing so this is really what the
progressive movement was about in the
late 1800s and early 1900s you know it
was not just a bunch of liberals seeking
big government you know what it was was
a bunch of reformers who were sick and
tired of inept corrupt government run by
party hacks that couldn't do anything
couldn't solve any problems and they
tried to bring about reforms like a
stronger presidency Teddy Roosevelt and
a merit-based bureaucracy much as you
might joke about it it was a hell of a
lot better than the spoil system that it
replaced in order to better equip the
government to perform effectively and
actually get something done that you
know basic things that people just
wanted done
it wasn't about big government just
about having government that could do
something and then do it you know
decently you know didn't have that
because the government the founders had
created was not working at that time
this is a brand-new time
but while these reforms surely help the
disjunction between government and
society only got worse over time because
society just kept changing so during the
last century the pace of social change
has been frenzied driven by stunning
technological innovations and an
increasingly complex and globalized
economy giving rise to a mind-boggling
array of vexing problems that weigh upon
Americans today terrorism persistent
poverty inequality a crumbling
infrastructure intense international
competition a broken immigration system
weak economic growth and more lots more
what we need is a government that is up
to the challenges thrust upon it by the
modern world whether it deals with these
challenges in the liberal way or
conservative ways to deal with them
somehow but what we have is a government
designed in the late 1700s when when
there was no sense that government
needed to do these things it was
designed for a primitive world nothing
like our own so what can we do well the
u.s. is clearly not going to shift to a
parliamentary system that's off the
table and other radical changes are off
the table too I would say but as William
Howell and I see it a practical strategy
is to seek out small constitutional
changes that promise big payoffs for
effective government here specifically
is an approach that we think makes good
sense with Congress the prime source of
dysfunction in this system Congress
should be moved to the periphery of the
lawmaking process whereas pathologies
can do less damage and presidents should
be moved to the center where they can do
the most good
no standing ovations this was it I'm so
disappointed but let me explain see with
the explanation everything will be ok ok
why presidents well they're wiring is
very different from Congress and
actually propels them to be relatively
speaking the champions of effective
government this is so regardless of
whether they're liberals or
conservatives Democrats or Republicans
seekers of big government or seekers of
small government quite unlike most
legislators presidents think in national
terms about national problems and their
overriding concern for their historical
legacies drives them to seek durable
solutions over the long haul depressing
national problems which members of
Congress just don't do needless to say
they're not always right they're not
always successful and conservative
presence would seek very different
policy solutions from liberal presidents
good but all presidents aspire to be the
nation's problem solver in chief and if
policymaking power can be shifted partly
not wholly just partly in their
direction and away from Congress which
is a basic disaster the prospects for
effective government will be much
improved a simple way to do this is
through a constitutional amendment that
grants presidents Universal fast-track
Authority the nation has 40 years of
positive experience with fast-track
Authority and international trade and
that same model would simply be applied
to all legislation presidents would
craft policy proposals which are likely
to be far more coherent well integrated
and effective than anything Congress
could come up with absolutely
absolutely take a look at congressional
legislation sometime and Congress would
be required to vote up or down can vote
no on those proposals within a specified
period of time and on a majoritarian
basis without changing them no delays no
filibusters no earmarks no loopholes for
special interests none of the things
that Congress loves on the other hand
Congress would retain the authority as
it has now to pass laws on its own if it
wants and presidents would retain the
authority to veto them so even if a
president favored policies that you or I
considered very troubling or extreme
fast-track would hardly make that
president a dictator so let's just
evaluate it from that both houses of
Congress would still need to give their
separate consent both the House and the
Senate before any proposal would become
law policy would be a three-way decision
not a presidential decision and the
court system and the separation of power
system would remain intact along with
the Bill of Rights everything's the same
we're just changing the decision model
about how legislation gets made the
entire constellation of checks and
balances would continue to limit what
presidents could do much as it has for
more than 200 years another fear perhaps
is that fast track would give rise to
presidential overreach right we've heard
a lot about that at this conference yes
yet fast track only deals with
legislation right it adds nothing to the
president's unilateral powers which are
what overreach is all about indeed a big
reason presidents have favored executive
orders and other unilateral actions is
that with Congress such a disaster the
legislative process is all but
unavailable for solving problems under
fast-track presidents would use
legislation more in unilateral action
less
so consider immigration for example
President Bush submitted immigration
reforms to Congress in 2005 and 2006
Obama did the same in 2013 all of these
bills had bipartisan majority support in
Congress both the House and the Senate
yet the first two went down on Senate
filibusters and the third went down when
John Boehner refused to bring it up for
a vote in the house the result no
immigration reform and a festering
immigration problem that continues to
today and a 2014 executive order by
Obama those cause must much
consternation on the right with
fast-track the nation would have passed
the bipartisan reform bill more than ten
years ago and there would have been no
Obama executive order I'm almost done
finally what about all the other
presidential systems in the world whose
experiences some say tend to give rise
to authoritarian rule by giving
presidents more power through fast-track
aren't we risking authoritarianism here
no or not in the first place we've had a
presidential system for 225 years and we
still don't have authoritarianism unless
it really twists the definition of that
so what's happening over there is not
happening over here
second fast-track is heavily constrained
by all the sorts of checks and balances
as I said and is hardly the sort of
reform that's going to produce a
dictator and third virtually every other
presidential system in the world is
either in Latin America or Africa and
then there's the Philippines all these
countries are less developed by far than
we are many of them are extremely poor
and their political systems that are
mired in corruption in spoils in
nepotism
in clientelism they look like a very
very very very early of
mayor version of American politics and
we had all those problems in spades
I so okay so they they have these very
serious problems of political culture
it's not at all surprising that those
systems are threatened by
authoritarianism but those systems are
extremely different from ours we're a
post-industrial society with a very
different political culture and I don't
think there's anything to fear that
we're gonna follow the same path as some
latin-american country we're not all
right so bottom line here in the United
States the most fundamental challenge
that we face is that our government is
profoundly ineffective at addressing the
many serious problems of modern times we
can't blame the founders for the bind
that we're in today they had no idea
what a modern society would look like
they designed a government for a tiny
agrarian nation and they assumed that as
society changed future generations would
change the Constitution to meet evolving
needs but future generations just didn't
do that instead they put it on a
pedestal to be worshipped the
Constitution is in fact among the
greatest achievements in the history of
human governance we have much to value
and much to be proud of but what we need
now is a healthier more objective
understanding of how the Constitution
actually affects our lives today and our
ability to govern ourselves and face up
to and solve the problems that actually
face us so modern America bears almost
no resemblance to the America of the
late 1700s and it's up to us as the
founders well recognized to modify the
Constitution to allow for effective
government in our own times so thank you
very much for listening I appreciate it
or the record I did request that
Hillsdale provide me a large hook or the
control to a trapdoor they did not so
don't blame me we'll see if I need them
howdy
I'm Frank Buckley I'm delighted to be
here I want to thank all the Hillsdale
people all of you people for having me
there are few institutions I can think
of that have more honorably defended the
best of America and the Constitution as
you have so it's a great honor
no like I confess when Brad here
described and excu me a Hillary Clinton
moment here but I'm going to power
through good when Brad here described me
as more or less an unreconstructed
Canadian I thought okay now the
mudslinging begins but in fact two years
back whilst I was still a Canadian I
wrote a book about the American
Constitution called the once and future
king in which I said we were moving
towards a different kind of Constitution
one of an all-powerful president that
was the book came out in April 6 of 2014
and nine days later nine days later I
became an American citizen that's right
tax day they said welcome to America
here's the Bell right and of course I
had you know the same impulse that every
new immigrant has when you become a
citizen I thought where we gonna do
about all these damn foreigners you know
time to roll up the ladder but but
indeed I did see a problem with not with
the Constitution perhaps so much as what
has become of American government and
our move towards strong presidential ism
and I think I probably will agree with
everything Terry said just now except
his conclusion but apart from that it
was absolutely right he's totally
spot-on because right now what we have
is a president who can make and unmake
laws without the consent of Congress he
can spend trillions of government
dollars on his own and he can take us to
war without
consent of Congress and the separation
of powers which many think the
cornerstone of the Constitution no
longer seems to bind him he is Rex
quondam Rex futurist the once and future
king and I said in the book that all of
this is irrevocable well when you write
a book you don't want to make things
sound too good to you and you know I
kind of hoped I'd horse sort of hope
that this would resonate with the
political theorists around I meant to be
provocative I didn't get much of
response what I hadn't realized is the
foundational you know principle of
political theory comes from the Big
Lebowski you know yeah well you know
that's just your opinion man right but
it wasn't just an opinion because I'd
done all the kind of bells and whistles
a regression analysis but we we love
doing it George Mason
III examined 89 presidential regimes and
50 parliamentary ones over a 39 year
period to see how they ranked on Freedom
House's measure of economic of political
freedom and I had 20 dependent variables
so I did stuff like you know you get a
Latin American variable to pick up
what's special about Latin America I and
you know I had about a hundred thousand
observations and I used you know all the
most sophisticated devices that I could
teach myself to do with Stata
panel corrected standard errors model
and what I found
NNE what anyway I crunched the numbers
was presidential governments were bad
for liberty okay I mean there was just
you know no way of slicing that so it
came out different and it was the same
conclusion that a lady called people
Norris and Harvard came to with a
slightly do somewhat different data set
and you know for all the theorists it
meant nothing but I'll say this for them
they had 200 years of history on their
side where things work pretty well and I
couldn't dismiss that right I mean I
thought I had shown that presidential
government's per se are bad for Liberty
but America I had to concede had been
breathe throughout its history my point
however was that it was free because it
was American that is it wasn't free
because of its Constitution it was freed
not because of the Constitution but in
spite of the Constitution and if
therefore you it seemed to me you wanted
to study American political freedom you
should look for it in Department's of
history or perhaps departments of
literature and certainly departments of
religion but not constitutional law
right and it seemed moreover to me that
we were following other third world
countries in the direction of an
all-powerful president right some of you
I think had that instinct or that sense
when Terry spoke a moment ago and
someone said we're there already right I
participated in focus groups we're
mostly well it was a Washington crowds
and he were all lawyers and they were
all liberals right you know and and and
we were talking about executive
authority and you know these were all
people who would have thought it was
peachy keen back a couple of years back
but this was last spring and they were
thinking about President Trump and they
thought we're gonna have to think about
this one right because what's happened
here is power throughout the country has
been drawn from the states to Washington
and within Washington from Congress to
the White House and it's it's it's it's
it's the grim logic of power
I mean power tends to centralize in one
person or one body I mean that's a
history Britain for example right I mean
when the framers were looking at
constitutions they really had only one
model they were looking at seriously
that was Britain and Britain's pit
height Constitution the Constitution of
Billy Pitt right where you had a House
of Lords that meant something you had a
House of Commons it meant something and
you had a king that meant something
right you know and in fact Pitt resigned
when the King refused to agree to
Catholic emancipation and Pitt thought
well I you know I'm stymied I can't do
anything
clearly I have to resign all right so
George a third did have that kind of
power there was a separation of powers
but that fast forward from that time to
fifty years thereafter and the great
Reform Act of 1832 and what have you got
you've got an all-powerful House of
Commons and the Lord's it's nothing and
the King is nothing and that's where we
are now right so that of course would
respond to all of the problems Terry had
with with Congress
the only problem of course is that it's
politically impossible to imagine that
kind of constitutional reform indeed any
constitutional reform that's why I don't
pay a heck of a lot of attention to
lawyers who come up with this amendment
or that amendment or I forget about it
right I've you know I've got better
things to do I mean spider solitaire
makes more sense you know reading those
Law Review articles so as I say the grim
logic of power is meant in parliamentary
countries that all parliamentary
countries tend to become constitutional
monarchies right and all presidential
regimes with about one or two exceptions
tend to become countries with an
all-powerful president by the way you
know what the other exception is this is
a trivia question right so America has
preserved its freedom in spite of the
fact that as a presidential form of
government you know what the other one
was I mean nobody gets it
it's Uruguay go figure right I mean they
should you know they should almost be
Anglophone right I mean they've got it
so good well that's the history of every
unhappy country pretty much to which
America has exported its constitution
the thing is you see that a permanent
equipoise of power between the branches
of a kind' imagined by the framers is as
unnatural as the Deacons one hosh a in
the poem of all Erwin
Oliver Wendell Holmes senior I don't you
guys know that poem and do you have to
read it you know in detention or
whatever you know that's where I learned
it right I mean but you might you know
incidentally you know not nobody under
40 knows this stuff you know none of
them know about the one hush a you know
none of them know about
without a country I mean you know all
this stuff that we kind of grew up with
it's gone
anyway you know so have you heard of the
wonderful one harsh a that was built in
such a logical way at last 100 years of
the day that's Oliver Wendell Holmes
senior the autocrat of the breakfast
table talking about what the
Constitution looks like in 1858 where
the whole country is going to hell
around him and what he says is you know
yeah I mean it's a satire on American
the American Constitution what he says
is you know the deccan has figured out
why Shea's that it's carriages break
down they always break down because one
part is weaker than the rest okay and so
what the deccan says is I'm gonna bake
one shape that's going to go on forever
all right and the trick is make every
part as strong as the rest
so no part wears out first right that's
the beauty of it I mean Madison couldn't
have done it better right and that's the
reason beyond a doubt a Shea breaks down
but doesn't wear out and so he made
every part as strong as the rest and it
just worked fine you know the carriage
just went on forever you know war of
1812 1840s you know and then a hundred
years to the day the new Deakin is
driving down with the Shea and all of a
sudden he finds himself sitting on a
pile of sawdust because everything broke
down at the same time right you see of
course if you're not a dunce how it went
to pieces all at once all at once and
nothing first just as bubbles do when
they burst end of the wonderful one
harsh a logic is logic that's all I'll
say right so much for logical theories
of government right I'm kind of an
empiricist I'd like to see what things
work and I have to admit the American
conservative the American Constitution
has worked wonderfully for 200 years but
now we're permitted to ask ourselves in
the Age of Obama like you know where
exactly are we heading right and and why
power tends to concentrate in the
presidency is all too easy to understand
a point insufficiently recognized I
think is that he is the country's head
of state right the sign of sure of
admiring
the subject of a thousand op-eds by
peggy noonan right I mean if there's
something bad that happens you need a
healing speech by the president give me
a break right the president cannot be as
he should be a figure of fun right
you're not permitted to laugh at these
guys these are buffoons for God's sakes
why would you ever Revere a politician
these are the lowest worms that God ever
permitted to walk in the face of the
year that's the only that attitude is
protective of Liberty but peggy noonan
ain't the president is also the only
person elected by the country as a whole
here's one the Congress as many right
he's opposed by the Speaker of the House
from someplace in Wisconsin or Ohio you
never heard of it's no contest
he also has this is Terry's point way
better incentives he is the Patriot King
he is falling Brooks Patriot King he is
George the third right Georgia through
his mother said George be a king right
that's how we got the American
Revolution right he was determined to
rule all right and you know the idea was
as opposed to all those you know corrupt
politicians in the age of Walpole he
would stand instead for the country as
the whole that's kind of what Terry is
saying right let's have somebody who
tries to govern for the whole country
well he does have those better
incentives I mean I guess I'll concede
yes it beats Robert Byrd okay no
question about that he also has control
of the information about the country he
can sit on a scandal until it disappears
and gridlock favors politicians I mean
that's that's kind of a hidden story
behind Terry here but it's it's it's
really the case every time a president
signs a bill he loses a little bit of
executive power he therefore has the
incentive never to do so because if he
doesn't do so he can say they didn't act
but I've got a pen
right all his incentives are not to do
deals that's that's why Obama's
touchiness about dealing with people
makes perfect sense of the whole point
is to maximize executive power well so
the interesting question here
for me at least is not you know why have
we not followed other presidential
countries down the cheerless path of an
all-powerful executive because we're not
quite there yet it's it's why we took so
long to get to Obama that's curious of
course they're never too much to be
praised George Mason right Ron you know
I'm from Mason saw it all coming right
it just took her 200 years to get there
right which is proof of exactly how
prescient he was you know you just could
see it all coming so what has happened I
mean we've had a good run but what's
happened to the country we left behind
that was a country with pascals
god-shaped hole in our hearts but in our
modern secular and celebrity-driven
culture it's not a God filled all it's
an Obama filled hole right that was a
country where people thought that their
children and where people had reason to
think their children would do better
than they would that was a country where
politicians were trusted that was a
country held together by a common
adherence to the public good with
generally accepted liberal principles
that was a country that taught its
people to love and honor America not to
despise it and that was a country that
could cut deals and as deal-making was
baked into the Constitution they could
make it work because in the end they
were all united with a common love of
America but that's not today's country
was i right to say all this is
irreversible how am i doing on time oh
hell no
I see three possibilities right I'll
give him names one is James the first
right James the first ruled without
parliament for about nine years between
1611 and 1620 but for a two-year
Parliament so a president who doesn't
need Congress at all the other
possibility I'll call Wayne Gretzky who
holds the record for hatrocks in the NHL
and a hat-trick here means you get
control of the presidency the
House in the Senate and when the Dems do
that it's then legislation on overdrive
and of course from the Republicans do
with nothing happens and the third
possibility I'll call Sam slick from
from thomas chandler Halliburton satire
of the 19th century the Yankee pedlar
who cuts deals the salesman right the
guy who can reach across to the other
side of the aisle like Ronald Reagan did
with Tip O'Neill or Dan Rostenkowski and
where does that leave us today in the
choice between Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump
Pascal again said you must make a choice
he set out to the free thinker the free
thinker said no I don't have to make a
choice Pascal said then you have already
made your choice now if your choices
Hillary seems to me to be James the
first right I'm not going to pursue that
since I'm pretty much out of time but
what about Trump right some
conservatives say he'd be just as
imperious as Hillary but he's gone out
of this way to deny it he's written some
pretty good speeches hasn't he or at
least I don't entirely disbelieve I see
him as Sam slick I see him as a deal
maker I see him as a guy who cuts deals
and that's been his life a guy who wrote
the book on the subject and if you know
Republicans get all three branches he
might even be Wayne Gretzky so you have
to choose between the certainty of one
person rule and the possibility of
constitutional rule on the other and we
know how Pascal would wager and those
are our choices they're our only choices
some people say we deserve better that
gives rise to a question about what we
desert what do we deserve Albert Camus
wrote about our just deserts in later on
show his mirror so when the book
appeared seen him demand a void of
empathy of affect a murderer and then 13
years later in American edition appear
at a translation Tammy wrote the
introduction he said Miller so is the
only Christ that you
deserve some people thought well he's
denigrating religion but then commute
immediately denied that no he was making
a comment not about Christ but about us
he said we don't deserve better that is
why I say Donald Trump is the only
Christ that we deserve but you don't
leave it there because the son of Oliver
winnable Holmes senior talked about
choices and he said as life is action
and passion it is necessary to take part
in the action and passion of the day
lest you be thought not to have lived
and so I've made my choice
thank you
all right we have a few minutes for
questions I'd ask that you state your
question very quickly I'm told by my
handlers we have to finish up in a few
minutes
so dr. moe you said you're ready a
fast-track would be the president would
propose legislation and then Congress
would have to either approve it or veto
it so essentially the roles of the
president and the Congress are reversed
in that situation is that how you would
describe it would it work basically like
that it would be a hybrid basically the
the president would have the right to
craft proposals and they would have
incentives to craft proposals that are
well integrated intellectually
justifiable holes that attack social
problems that presidency is particularly
important and the real key to it is that
they can put that on Congress's agenda
and Congress can't do what it always
does it can't reach in and start taking
out things that they don't like and
putting in all sorts of special interest
provisions and basically gutting the
thing which has happens on it happens
all the time
so under fast-track they have to vote on
this proposal
now presidents aren't going to design
those proposals without an eye to
Congress they're going to try to design
them in such a way that they're coherent
but also that they can attract
majorities and that's what was done in
the immigration case right so then
Congress would get a chance to vote in
the Senate and in the house and only if
both the Senate and the house pass it
right a majoritarian grounds will it
become the law right so that's the
fast-track way of passing laws but
Congress can go ahead and pass laws on
its own in any way it wants just like it
does now right so that's not done away
with right we're just adding a new
component that allows policymaking to be
streamlined and gives the champion of
effective government a chance right to
craft policies that Congress can't fool
with and to the extent that these
policies become the focus of legislative
attention and
I think the country will get much more
effective policies down the road yeah
may I add something to that so I want to
say to professor Moe I think I think he
should be happier about the situation we
have today than he is because I think
the situation we have is some version of
of the change that he that he proposes
that that is to say with the situation
that we have you think about it where
you have your discretion for
administrative agencies they make
regulations and then it's very very
difficult for Congress to undo those
right undo those regulations in fact by
the way I'm here with my with my 16 year
old this week and we went into both the
House and Senate galleries yesterday and
on both sides and both chambers the
legislation that was being discussed
we're a tense which are gonna be utterly
fruitless I can assure you to try to
rein in a particular administrative
agency so that the point is the the
situation we have today is in fact you
do have ruled by presidential initiative
the president or the agencies under his
control make laws
we call them regulations and then
Congress only if it is able to pass a
law of its own in in you know in
contrast only if it's able to pass the
House passed the Senate overcome
filibuster then itself be presented to
the president and enacted into law
that's the only way in which Congress
can actually do anything about it so in
fact I think you should be happier
because I think we already we already do
have some version of the system that
you're calling for I would say we have
much smaller versions of it because
really the types of regulations that
you're talking about are issued under
delegation that exists within much
bigger pieces of legislation and and
what we're talking about and fast track
process most of the time are those big
pieces of legislation that normally
don't go anywhere in Congress and turn
out to be train wrecks if they if they
ever do pass right and so what we want
is a process within Congress where
really important pieces of legislation
that really do
dress national problems can actually be
put together in a coherent way that
makes sense
intellectually and can be passed yes
could you university all of the
university take example from Hillsdale
College and bring conservative speaker
to the universities as you were as
invited over here because the brainwash
a lot of the universities across the
country they do not teach independent
thinking because if you are independent
you be out of university we have an
office speech
I wonder if they any university you can
persuade them but for example I can come
and speak about conservatives as you
come over here and you speak your mind
thank ok ok I should just make one
comment since to my knowledge this is
not some sort of conspiracy you know to
keep ideas out of universities I think
what what there are plenty of people on
campus they're you know they're
conservative organizations at Stanford
for instance who would be interested in
bringing in speakers to talk on these
kinds of topics and if somebody here
wanted to contact them I'm sure
something could be arranged whether
anybody would show up is another
question right yeah
well because probably I don't know what
the statistics are but probably
nine-tenths of the people on campus or
liberals right I didn't do this I'm just
describing the situation right you're
the guy we have right here yeah right
right so so this is just the lay of the
land right and it's not something I'm
happy about I wish I wish campuses were
much more diverse than they are but this
is the reality and in one way of making
incursions which I would favor is to go
ahead and do it
these organizations to bring people in
and advertise them and try to stir up
some activity maybe have some debates
let me and you know this is that's
usually not my thing my thing is to sit
in my office for eight hours with the
door closed you can you can count on me
I'll take care of that let me tell you
where lunch is going to be which is in
the Grand Ballroom just around the
corner where dinner was let me encourage
all of you to continue this conversation
over lunch unfortunately we're butting
up against lunch I've told so we have to
end it here but thank you very much for
your time
you